I have a surprise and it is possibly the
best thing to potentially ever happen to
anyone anywhere in the history of the
universe ladies and gentlemen the world
famous little Sebastian what yes oh my
God
I never thought I'd get to meet him
well done Leslie well done little
Sebastian made his debut at the last
Harvest Festival in 1987 and he was an
instant phenomenon for the next few
years Sebastian was the number one boy's
name in Pawnee and the number three
girl's name so what am I missing what's
the deal with this Pony he's not a pony
man he's a mini horse there's a big
difference well then why is he so famous
does he do something what does he do son
this horse has an honorary degree from
Notre Dame we all need to be very
careful okay remember this little guy's
25 now and he has cataracts in both eyes
he has severe arthritis Jerry's gonna
look after him yes I am we are both on
the same diabetes medication are you my
glue control buddy are you huh isn't it
amazing yeah I just got to be honest I
don't know what the big deal is
get out
been staring at this board for days
so close to putting it together there's
got to be something we missed let's go
over this again the video shows that the
pie came from a high angle
so it would have hit your face
like this
mm-hmm
Don't Close Your Eyes
no no it actually was from up higher
is that about right yeah good clean
yourself up let's do this again
hey Ann what happened I just saw you a
few hours ago and you were fine not like
damn you're fine but fine health-wise my
body has no fat to protect itself from
disease things happen very quickly
listen to me it's very important that
you replenish my body with electrolytes
after every involuntary loss of bodily
fluids oh boy my body tends to lose a
lot of fluids when it's sick my brain is
on fire I'm dying
well you definitely have the flu
oh my God
the microchip has been compromised
I vomited somewhere in this room
I don't remember where though
wait you might want to check that drawer
stop
pooping
you don't even know one thing I didn't
even say what they can do she asked me
the whole thing and I didn't even do it
once I'm like an elephant okay if I walk
into a room it's like okay he's in there
Baba Boy
turn this music down
[Music]
um
is this everybody and took a cab times
in the trunk Jerry's on the roof
all right where to First
your mother's butt
[Laughter]
I'm so alone
if even one of you thinks about dry
heaving in my car you're all walking
home okay your eyes are glassy oh my God
oh my God is she sick are you sick no
yeah she's sick that's why I'm wearing
this and misting myself with hand
sanitizer I'm not sick I just have
allergies okay I took a Claritin and I
threw that up so I took another one I
threw that up and then I took a third
and it stayed down I'm getting better
all right you're burning up you're
burning up what I have to get out of
here I have 2.8 body fat my body's like
a microchip a grain of sand could
destroy it
my butt is microchip
Leslie no I can't I can't go home I have
to get ready for the Chamber of Secrets
Commerce if this meeting does not go
perfectly then the Harvest Festival is
going to be over before it began I
cannot go home okay then who's your
doctor
and my doctor
most beautiful nurse in the world
come on oh God no I'm hot now it's
really hot in here okay well that's
Leslie I typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems
and Wyatt that I know I just don't think
he'd be happy sitting here faffing
around I'm not faffing around I've sunk
myself into my hobbies here
I'll show you my claymation project okay
now I've been working pretty hard on
this and
I think it's really good so just hang on
to your hat okay okay here we go
upgrade
[Music]
did you pause it no I hang on
oh my God
that's the whole thing
that's three weeks of work you're gonna
be okay no no no no I'm not you see in
my head I thought that was really really
cool in fact I I emailed Leslie two days
ago and I compared it to Avatar Chris
and how can it not be longer hey bro
listen I was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of B-25
Mitchell Panchito aircraft oh for me
don't sass me and I went to this website
and this ad popped up that said Hey Ron
Swanson check out this great offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell
like how do they know who you are yeah
okay
um there are these things called cookies
where like if you go to a site and buy
something it'll remember you and then
create ads for other stuff you might
want to buy so it learns information
about me
seems like an invasion of privacy dude
if you think that's bad go to Google
Earth and type in your address
if I thought you were serious I'd be
offended pert but I know that we're
buddies I know you wouldn't do that to
me but no this is a birthmark purd okay
this is the little scar I got when I was
nine and I fell off my bike so no I'm
not perfect I can't look away it's a
it's amazing okay wait no here's the
best part okay uh that's all the time we
have here on you heard I'm heard happily
channel four more like turd crapley
[Applause]
so while they repaint the lines in the
parking lot we're asking everyone to do
street parking I'm not street parking my
Mercedes well everyone is I'm doing it
because nobody wants to steal a Saturn
all right uh moving on to recycling
you okay Ron just a little tooth pain
I'm fine continue okay each department
will be getting blue bins
do you need to go to the dentist Ron I
don't like dentists just a second
hey no no no no no no no no no
[Applause]
no no no no no no no
no
oh my God I'm sorry everybody what were
we talking about recycling dentist
pulled the tooth out yesterday
but it's always a good idea to
demonstrate to your co-workers that you
are capable of withstanding a tremendous
amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see Tom faint
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I couldn't afford enough premium carpet
to get us to the stage I mean it was a
short walk but it was pretty luxurious
right
everybody smile away
get up and make it happen
I'm waiting on my arm Andy
I'm holding the dog he is peeing he's
now peeing and putting him down
[Music]
there's no scares how do I get to the
stage
thank you
[Music]
hey